[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 30 juin nouvelle édition
du 7 8 journal sur tv 78 bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez tout de suite les
titres
le site a été surnommée la mère des
déchets le nettoyage de la décharge
sauvage de carrières sous poissy a
démarré depuis janvier dernier état
département des yvelines et
collectivités ont fait le point sur la
situation
c'est le résultat surprise de ce second
tour des élections municipales là
derrière fief historique du parti
communiste aura un maire de droite la
liste menée par nicolas d'un vilain
remporté dimanche face à la maire
sortante nelly duthu interview enfin les
vacances d'été approchent et encore plus
avec cette période particulière avec des
écoles fermées pendant deux mois des
cahiers de vacances seront de sortie
certains sont même imaginer dans les
yvelines
reportage mais avant de développer ces
titres ce sujet à l'envergure régional
ile de france a lancé aujourd'hui son
budget participatif est de grands
dossiers comme de micro projets sont
concernés
le but de ce dispositif associé les
franciliens à la transformation
écologique de leur région et les
précisions de mélanie poté
une démarche 100% dématérialisé depuis
ce mardi 30 juin les franciliens peuvent
proposer leurs projets leurs envies
autour de cinq thèmes une première porte
d'entrée assez classique avec des crocs
projets d'investissements pour des
villes ou des intercommunalités donc des
projets qui sont des projets
structurants à pourront aller jusqu'à
plusieurs millions d'euros mais vous
aurez aussi des microprojets et la
possibilité de déposer des micro projets
jusqu'à 10000 euros
et là n'importe quelle association
pourra ou n'importe quel individu mais
se structurant ensuite en association si
son projet est retenu pour à déposer sur
la plate forme pour ce lancement de
projets la région propose 100 millions
d'euros montant qui atteindra 500
millions d'ici 2024
les franciliens ont jusqu'au 14 août
pour déposer un dossier sur le site
dédié
on a souhaité que les projets
correspondent un certain nombre de
critères tout d'abord respecte l'intérêt
général
respect qu une logique de participation
citoyenne respecte les valeurs de la
république et de la laïcité
ce qui est extrêmement important
particulièrement aujourd'hui fassent
preuve de bienveillance et de respect
d'autrui
tiennent en compte la solidarité et
l'inclusion sociale l'équité
territoriale
les franciliens seront ensuite appelés à
voter du 18 septembre 2 octobre pour
s'exprimer et être âgé de plus de 15 ans
elle les premiers projets retenus seront
annoncés à l'occasion de la commission
permanente du mois d'octobre dans
l'actualité également nous vous en
parlions la semaine dernière cette
grande campagne de dépistage alaa
qu'ovide 19 lancers en ile de france 32
communes de plus de 10 mille habitants
été identifiés pour ces tests pcr
c'est-à-dire par prélèvement nasal
objectifs et identifier les éventuelles
foyers épidémiques dormant dans les
villes concernées ci se trouve dans les
yvelines mantes la jolie les mureaux
lui-même
la ville trappe et enfin et l'encours
est d'ailleurs à elancourt le dépistage
s'effectuera demain mercredi sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville
c'est entre 9 heures et 18 heures la
municipalité indique que ces tests sont
gratuits et ouverts à tous les citoyens
en tout la campagne en ile-de-france va
concerner 1,3 million d'habitants
je vous le disais dans les titres la
première phase de nettoyage de la
décharge sauvage de carrières sous
poissy a débuté en janvier dernier cette
opération est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre l'état les
différentes collectivités territoriales
le tout piloté par le département des
yvelines et trois entreprises privées un
point sur la situation a été fait hier
lundi le reportage de nicolas landry et
de patrick jacques de dixmude opération
nettoyage de la décharge sauvage de
carrières sous poissy une première phase
lancée au mois de janvier 2020 avec déjà
65 % de l'amac collecter spécialisée
dans le recyclage des matériaux
l'entreprise biche et à filiale du
groupe colas est chargé de trier et
valoriser les déchets notamment avec
cette plateforme de tri dans la plaine
on va effectuer un premier tri ce qui va
nous permettre de séparer les gros
éléments
donc tout ce qui est là qui va pas
pouvoir être valorisé la partie 30,80
donc c'est ce tapis là sur lesquels on a
installé un aspirateur donc qui va
aspirer les éléments légers ensuite le
reste passe sur le tapis centrale tombe
dans le band tri donc à l'intérieur de
la cabine y un tapis principal quatre
personnes qui sont chante deux et deux
de chaque côté et qui vont trier le
département a sélectionné trois
entreprises dans le cadre de cette
opération avec une mission de
surveillance et de pose de clôture pour
protéger cet espace un investissement
d'1 25 million d'euros de l'état et du
conseil départemental
vous avez là la démonstration comme
quand là
il ya coordination et volonté de la part
des acteurs publics lorsqu'ils s'y
mettait les moyens barre il arrive à des
résultats spectaculaires
nous voulions voir le résultat du
travail collectif des divers acteurs
publics et privés je parle des
entreprises et acteurs publics ses
pensées départementale communauté
urbaine l'epamsa qui est un
établissement public de l'état je le
rappelle est l'état dans ce travers le
président a prononcé le chiffre de huit
cent mille euros
nous devons l'engagement du préfet de
région ile de france une deuxième phase
de nettoyage va être lancée au mois
d'août 2020 objectif dépolluer 75% de la
plaine de déchets d'ici à la fin de
l'année un projet d'aménagement d'un
espace naturel protégé en cours de
réflexion est prévu une fois la
dépollution terminée
les élections municipales sont
maintenant passés ce sont désormais les
conseils d'installation qui vont avoir
lieu dans les prochains jours après ce
second tour dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines on comptera
bientôt quatre nouveaux maires à
l'échelle de l'agglomération qui
viennent s'ajouter en fait à un autre
nouveau celui de montigny le bretonneux
qui a été élu dès le premier tour
parmi ces nouveaux maires la verrière
aura un édile à droite une petite
révolution pour ce bastion communiste
depuis 1977 avec nos nicolas dainville
bonsoir bonsoir mais vous êtes la tête
de liste élue avec une nouvelle
dynamique pour la verrière une
candidature divers droite qui l'a donc
emporté avec 47 52 % des suffrages face
au liste de la maire sortante communiste
n'est did you tu es celle de son ancien
un ancien premier adjoint jean yves
blais une première question est ce que
déjà vous vous attendiez à pareil
résultat finalement vous êtes le le
premier surpris on rappelle un contexte
la verrière commune ancré à gauche et au
1er tour vous étiez classé en deuxième
position derrière la maire sortante
mais à écouter on sentait bien sur le
terrain qui a vu une vraie envie de
changement et un profond sentiment que
il fallait une nouvelle dynamique
impulsée un nouveau souffle à notre
commune
ça on l'a senti dans tous nos porte à
porte on est l'équipe sans étiquette caf
un long travail de terrain qui n'a pas
commencé il ya quelques mois mais qui a
commencé il ya plus de six ans et ça
qu'on n'a jamais lâché le terrain on a
toujours été présent on a toujours
essayé d'être au service des verriers
roi des habitants de défendre nos
valeurs
le convictions et je pense que c'est
tout seul au travail qui a payé dimanche
dernier donc de votre point de vue ce
n'est pas uniquement la conséquence
d'une division à gauche de liste issue
de l'ancienne majorité qui se présentait
face à la vôtre écoutez bien évidemment
que cela a joué mais ça s'ajoute à ce
sentiment d'insatisfaction qui est très
très présents dans notre commune
effectivement il ya bien des raisons à
cette division avec deux équipes qui ne
se faisait plus confiance qui ne faisait
plus confiance à la maire sortante et
donc a effectivement que tout ce climat
là à jouer à jouer dans le niveau
d'insatisfaction est donc dans cette
envie d'alternance une commune de la
verrière avec un maire avec une
sensibilité à droite est ce que elle va
être totalement différente est ce que
vous allez faire totalement table rase
du passé ou peut-être vous appuyer sur
des choses qui avait était bien fait
aussi par la majorité précédente
comment allez vous vous positionnez
alors moi effectivement j'ai des
convictions politiques et je ne m'en
cache pas mais l'équipe elle est bien
sans étiquette il ya des gens de divers
gauche a des gens qui sont sentis à des
gens qui n'ont aucun aucune appartenance
politique est l'ambition de cette équipe
c'est de faire des belles choses pour
notre commune donc ce qui est bien ce qu
a bien été fait par le mandat passé et
d'un doctorat pour les consolident mais
on a envie d'apporter une nouvelle
dynamique un nouveau souffle sur un
certain nombre de sujets de changer de
logiciel aussi sur un grand nombre
d'enjeux
je pense à l'éducation on a envie de
miser sur la réussite avec du soutien
scolaire gratuit avec eux une étude
dirigée avec eux un cap milles sur les
innovations pédagogiques pour
transmettre aux jeunes dans la réussite
grâce notamment aux tablettes tactiles
grâce aux cours de programmation
numérique on a envie misait sur la
sécurité avec des médiateurs avec un
lien renforcé avec la police nationale
pour veiller au calme dans nos quartiers
et puis on a envie sur tous les grands
sujets de mobiliser les partenaires pour
essayer d'aboutir sur ce fameux dossier
des bécanes qui est un dossier important
pour développer la verrière sur le
dossier du pont de lavilledieu ou encore
l'enfouissement des lignes à haute
tension
tous ces sujets là on a envie de
travailler en confiance avec nos
partenaires que ce soit l'agglomération
le département ou la région
alors c'est un scrutin des municipales
où l'abstention s'est distingué même si
c'est à la verrière qu'on a le plus voté
à saint quentin en yvelines
quand on regarde plus précisément vos
résultats nicolas dainville vous avez
obtenu alors un peu moins de 23 % des
électeurs inscrits alors je parle bien
du pourcentage des inscrits et non des
bulletins exprimés est ce que ça ça va
poser un souci sur la légitimité pour
les prochaines l'épreuve les six
prochaines années pardon à la tête de la
verrière non écoutés l'élection mois eu
lieu on a fort taux de participation
comme vous l'avez dire des plus élevées
de l'agglomération le choix il est quand
même clairement ça a été un choix de
changement d'un profond dynamisme
retrouvé pour notre commune
mais effectivement moi je suis mère de
tous les verres miroir est donc
maintenant fort a semblé apaiser la
campagne elle est derrière nous il ya eu
le temps de la campagne maintenant c'est
le temps du travail et donc dès samedi
après ce conseil j'ai envie qu'on se
mette au travail au plus vite qu'avec
l'ensemble de mon équipe pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses tout faire se
donner à 100% pour notre commune pour
rendre la verrière plus verte plus
vivante plus belle plus sûres
et puis plus dynamique quelles sont vos
premières priorités vous avez parlé de
des priorités sur le mandat on pense
forcément à cette crise de lakovic 19
qui est encore en cours qui a eu son lot
de conséquences
le sel de creuser les inégalités de
faire augmenter le chômage des
thématiques les inégalités et le chômage
qui concerne cette commune de la
verrière ça va faire partie de vos
premières priorités en tout cas la gérer
cette crise au niveau local bien sûr la
question de l'emploi elle est primordial
on propose et on a va mettre en place un
système de mentorat pour que des jeunes
soient coachés par des salariés saint
quentinois ont valsé également mettre en
place de toute urgence d'une équipe de
médiateurs sur le terrain pour veiller
au calme
on va travailler sur l'éducation en
mettant en place le programme du
département et de l'agglomération sur
les innovations pédagogiques pour
vraiment que ce cap sur la réussite
scolaire il soit immédiatement mis en
place et puis la première priorité ça va
être ces grandes vacances qui arrivent
il faut des animations pour nos jeunes
on a déjà discuté un petit peu avec les
les agents du pro
de vacances après nantes qui est un
programme pour concentrer les jeunes sur
les fondamentaux et leur transmettre les
fondamentaux les miser sur le soutien
scolaire
mais de manière aussi ludique donc tout
cela on va mettre ça sur la table là
dans les jours qui viennent
donc voilà il ya un travail énorme et
puis une dernière priorité qu'on a peu
évoqué pendant cette campagne mais c'est
tous les enjeux des finances publiques
c'est vrai que le budget de la verrière
à mon avis est très compliqué on est en
train là de de découvrir un certain
nombre de choses donc il ya des
décisions des premières décisions qu'on
qui vont devoir être prises dans les
jours qui viennent donc ces voix là tous
ses priorités là c'est ce sur quoi on va
travailler là très très rapidement dès
samedi prochain et une dernière question
on le rappelle ces élections municipales
étaient aussi des élections
communautaire pour désigner les élus
qu'ils allaient s'y siéger au sein des
intercommunalités vous allez justement
siéger dans l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise ça c'est une nouveauté
alors on peut imaginer peut-être comme
vice président vous étiez déjà vous êtes
pardon actuellement conseiller
départemental du canton de trappes où
vous avez pris la succession de jean
michel fourgous qui avait laissé son
poste après son élection comme président
de saint quentin en yvelines
est ce que vous comptez conserver toutes
ses casquettes peut-être vous libérer de
votre mandat départemental
non bien évidemment que dans le lien
entre le département et la ville
il est fondamental j'ai vu un nombre de
dossiers avec du temps beaucoup de temps
perdu justement parce que ce lien il
était pas renforcer justement parce que
notre communauté troupe isolé là c'est
une chance historique c'est d'avoir le
département et l'agglomération à nos
côtés plus la région et donc quand on
associe tous ses partenaires on peut
faire des miracles
en tout cas moi je compte bien m'appuyer
sur tous ses partenaires pour capter des
financements aller les chercher et
financé à un grand nombre de projets
donc c'est très important et pour
répondre un petit peu plus directement à
vos questions sur le l'agglomération
c'est un parent d de nos principaux
partenaires
je devrai occupait le poste de
vice-président à l'emploi et donc ça
permettra d'avoir une efficacité sur ces
sujets là pour essayer de résoudre ce
problème
du chômage qui est beaucoup trop
important je vous le rappelle que de 16%
à la verrière le double que la moyenne
des villes telles que le conseil
d'installation de saint quentin en
yvelines aura lieu le 11 juillet merci
nicolas dainville d'avoir été avec nous
à vous vainqueur de ces élections à la
verrière futur maire de la verrière donc
un ce n'est pas encore officiel puisque
le conseil d'installation aura lieu ce
samedi le centre commercial ouvrira ses
portes fin août à plaisir opensky
désormais nommé mon grand plaisir
accueillera trente neuf boutiques et 12
restaurants sur une surface de près de
quarante mille mètres carrés une session
de recrutement est lancée par pôle
emploi plaisir et la mission locale ski
ou à 16,25 une cinquantaine de poste est
à pourvoir et de la vente à la
restauration en raison du contexte
sanitaire
l'opération se déroulera en ligne les
candidatures sont à déposer sur le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran jusqu'au
15 juillet prochain
une fois en ligne il suffit de taper le
mot plaisir en mots clés dans la barre
de recherche pour accéder à ces offres
c'est une idée justement pour relancer
l'emploi et créer des vocations pour les
jeunes l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines lançons summer camp pneus
numérique et dix jours d'initiation aux
métiers du numérique qui se dérouleront
du 20 au 31 juillet s'est adressé aux
jeunes saint quentinois de 16 à 25 ans
elle les détails dans ce sujet de
nicolas dandois découvrir les activités
d'un développeur web d'un community
manager d'un spécialiste en objets
connectés ou en cyber sécurité
le principe du summer campus numérique
du 20 au 31 juillet organisé par saint
quentin en yvelines en collaboration
avec pop school et o'clock ces
structures de formation ont préparé
plusieurs ateliers
le format des ateliers va être dépensé
autour d'une progression qui permet de
s'intéresser d'abord de manière large à
différents métiers et ensuite de
restreindre le périmètre progressivement
par exemple sur le développement web
les jaunes vont pour les jeunes vont
pouvoir développer des petits sites
internet et donc découvrir la
programmation découvrir la mise en page
des éléments sur une page web
l'interactivité destiné aux jeunes âgés
de 16 à 25 ans une centaine de personnes
pourra participer aux dix jours
d'initiation en présentiel à la
pépinière d'entreprises promo paul
ou à distance dans les missions locales
ou à la cité des métiers
objectif favoriser les emplois dans le
numérique dans un contexte de crise
économique
j'en laisse entreprise de saint quentin
en yvelines qui nous disent qu'elles ont
besoin de ses compétences là et donc on
essaie de mettre en adéquation la
demande d'emploi avec l'offre d'emploi
sur la filière du numérique nous avons 5
à 6000 emplois non pourvus sur saint
quentin en yvelines
inscription gratuite et obligatoire en
fonction des places disponibles avant le
16 juillet prochain
autre formation aux normes dans la
restauration un sujet des plus
importants avec un secteur qui se
relancent peu à peu depuis le début du
mois de juin et ce en plein contexte de
crise sanitaire ces formations elles
sont proposées par une entreprise basé à
elancourt trois questions posées par
nicolas d'andrus une entreprise n'est
dédié à toute la partie réglementation
pour les dirigeants et le personnel dans
les métiers de bouche
donc nous parlons essentiellement aux
restaurateurs ou boulanger au boucher
donc toutes les personnes qui manipulent
des denrées andy alimentaire nous
travaillons sur trois axes comment
répondre à la réglementation et
l'hygiène que toute la partie
haccp comment répondre à la répression
des fraudes
donc tout ce qui est information
conseillé aux consommateurs
et comment répondre à la réglementation
ou droit du travail
durant le confinement nous on a souhaité
garder le contact avec avec nos clients
et les autres n'a organisé environ tous
les quinze jours un webinar pour
permettre aux restaurateurs les mêmes
aux futurs restaurateurs de pouvoir
participer et avoir des informations sur
comment s'adapter comment mettre en
place certaines choses
c'est une formation qu'on a voulu simple
abordable et puis aussi pas très longue
donc 4 dure sept heures on a beaucoup de
d'informations qui nous sont parvenues
donc de l'état et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une formation
qui complètement collés au protocole et
qui leur permet de répondre à ce
protocole dont sur toutes les lignes
quand je mets en place mon plan de
maîtrise sanitaire renforcée durant
qu'ovide comment je vais communiquer à
mai avec les salariés pour qu'ils
puissent être partie prenante de cette
nouvelle méthodologie de travail
après la rentrée obligatoire est totale
depuis le 22 juin dernier vendredi déjà
c'est le début des vacances estivales
pour les écoliers et c'est une tradition
les cahiers de vacances vont accompagner
à cette année encore de nombreux enfants
certains ont été imaginés d'ailleurs
dans les yvelines des cahiers de
vacances made in yvelines comme jules et
léonie h à tous et on en parle avec
aurélien 11 ils sont attendus par les
enfants et surtout les parents les
cahiers de vacances connaissent chaque
été un grand succès parmi toutes ces
références l'une d'elles a été conçu à
chatou dans les yvelines
alors qu'elle est professeur des écoles
virginie beke ne trouve pas son bonheur
dans les cahiers existants pour ses
enfants elle décide de se lancer dans
l'aventuré jules et léonie il ya cinq
ans j'ai eu cette idée de
de créer des cahiers de vacances qu'ils
fassent grandir l'enfant dans toutes ses
dimensions qui est pas que la partie
scolaire mais qui a aussi des aspects
qui vraiment lui fasse prendre confiance
en lui
les deux personnages voyage au coeur de
l'histoire tout en faisant réviser les
notions de l'année écoulée un frère et
une soeur nés sous le crayon de laëtitia
ami d'enfance de la fondatrice des
cahiers nous sommes tombés tout de suite
d'accord sur une ambiance graphique et
coloré
on voulait des cahiers qui soit à la
fois ludique et sérieux mais que le côté
ludique apporte la dimension d'apprendre
en s'amusant aux enfants et jules leoni
ont été rejoints par une petite mascotte
qui s'appelle pouic pouic le canard pour
apporter cette petite touche d'humour
décalé chaque cahier nécessite un an
d'écriture commercialisé pour la
première fois en 2019 dans les
librairies et de grandes enseignes
culturelles
il existe pour l'instant trois niveaux
l'année dernière on en a imprimé 3000
donc les trois confondues
on a quasiment tout vendu donc ça
c'était voilà on était contente avec
laeticia parce que c'est un peu le flou
artistique on savait pas trop et donc
cette année on en a un prix mais trois
fois plus deux autres niveaux devrait
être disponible l'année prochaine
en plus des exercices de maths et de
français les cahiers propose des petites
pépites moment à partager en famille ou
encore des leçons de bonne heure c'était
une première à la commanderie à
elancourt un marché du terroir étaient
proposés avec 24 producteurs des stands
et se passer pour respecter les règles
sanitaires
l objectif de cet événement organisé par
le rotary-club d'elancourt haute vallée
de chevreuse récolter des fonds pour les
reverser ensuite à des associations qui
ont été touchés par la crise du
coronavirus est les propos sont
recueillis par mathilde de demi on est
heureux d'être là on est aussi heureux
de faire connaître un commanderie parce
que c'est une équipe qui cherche à
développer son action pour la culture et
donc les faire connaître fait partie de
notre objectif
on est en plein air donc les règles
sanitaires ne sont pas très très
contraignante
on a un très grand espace s'il ya
beaucoup d espaces entre les stands
donc on peut accueillir jusqu'à 250
personnes sans aucun problème prochaine
action du rotary club en octobre
prochain au château de dampierre c'est
une escapade gourmande qui vous sera
proposé
et puis ce week-end c'était également le
retour des grandes eaux nocturnes au
château de versailles un rendez vous
incontournable de l'été
elles se dérouleront tous les samedis
soir de la saison jusqu'au 19 septembre
un spectacle féerique des bosquets
fontaines et bassins mise en eau et en
lumières et le cloud comme grand final
bien sûr le feu d'artifice tarifs de 26
à 30 euros voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci d'avoir suivi très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]